Quantencomputer sind dafür gedacht, Probleme zu lösen, die klassische Computer
nicht bewältigen können – Dinge
wie die Suche nach den richtigen Materialien, um
Carbon Capture zu ermöglichen und wirklich
im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel voranzukommen, oder
effizientere Düngemittel zu entwickeln, die
die Erde nicht schädigen, aber gleichzeitig die
Nahrungsmittelversorgungskette aufrechterhalten, die wir brauchen, um die Welt zu ernähren.
Außerdem gibt es grundlegende Fragen darüber, wie unser Universum
zusammengesetzt ist und wie sich Materie auf atomarer
und subatomarer Ebene verhält – das müssen wir verstehen.
Das ist die nächste Grenze.
Schauen wir uns einen Bereich an, in dem bereits geforscht wird:
die Suche nach neuen Batterien.
Batterien haben unser Leben verändert, weil wir dadurch
Computer und Smartphones überallhin mitnehmen können.
Aber es gibt noch mehr zu tun – Batterien sind entscheidend
für unsere saubere Energiezukunft.
Ob für Elektroautos oder wirklich
zur Förderung erneuerbarer Energien –
wir brauchen eine grundlegend andere Chemie,
um die Batterien
von morgen zu schaffen. Quantencomputing
würde es uns ermöglichen, effektiv ins Innere einer Batterie zu schauen
– mitten in ihren hochkomplexen Reaktionen –, damit wir
über neue Materialien
und die Struktur der Batterien nachdenken können, die gebraucht werden,
um die nächste Gerätegeneration zu versorgen.
Wie kommen wir dorthin? Indem wir die weltweit fortschrittlichsten Quantengeräte
und eine Entwicklungsplattform bauen
und sie der Welt zugänglich machen.
Nur wenn wir jetzt zusammenarbeiten,
werden wir in der Lage sein, die Probleme zu lösen, vor denen wir
gemeinsam in der Zukunft stehen werden.